i want to start with what we just heard
right there coach harbaugh calling it
basically the best performance that he
had seen from lamar jackson coming back
to beat the colts the colts had the
ravens all over the ropes in this game
how was baltimore able to do it again in
that fourth quarter to come get the win
lamar was absolutely outstanding and the
one thing that really stood out to me
post game is when he said look
everything is starting to slow down to
me
he's starting to really read the
defenses he's starting to feel
comfortable when he's dropping back and
he understands what the defense is
trying to do absolutely incredible um
performance mind but also you look at a
guy like marquis brown how i'm extremely
proud of marquis brown because of the
way he's bounced back he's no longer
just a deep threat they're getting them
the ball intermediately in a short
passing game and he's doing his thing
just really proud of that young man and
what he's accomplished this last couple
weeks
mark andrews as well i mean i i think
this is you sort of saw the best of what
the ravens can be that's what the fourth
quarter felt like to me now the rest of
the game they look bad and i this season
for baltimore could be so much different
i mean if you think about the kansas
city game if clyde edwards lair doesn't
fumble they in all likelihood lose that
game you know they would have lost to
kansas city at home in that game now the
colts game if it's not for a miracle
fourth quarter comeback that included
two two-point conversions to go get the
win they would have also lost to a
struggling indie team at home so they
could very easily be a two win three
loss team right now but instead they're
four and one based on what we've seen
lamar jackson do in these four quarters
and probably the most impressive thing
is that he's doing it all with his arm
from the pocket three-step drop getting
the ball out finding open receivers
multitude of guys guys out of the
backfield and when he needs to scramble
he'll go create some magic but it's from
the pocket first and he looks so much
more comfortable back there wheeling and
dealing whether it's deep intermediate
or the short stuff i'm really impressed
yeah the thing about it too is he had
opportunities when he dropped back to
take off and run and i show i saw his
patience i saw the discipline he didn't
want to take off he stood in the pocket
he continued to survey the field and he
made some incredible plays man and i was
just i was sitting back like wow is this
going to be the new lamar jackson and
that's where he has to get to he has to
get to the point where he can play like
that every single week and just show a
level of consistency
yeah and earlier earlier in the game you
know what i mean like this this game
very easily and was close to being
completely out of hand by the time he
got back to it i want to hit indy
because we have been critical of winds
critical of this new colts team and what
they're trying to put together there in
indianapolis what did you think of the
way they got the run game going got
jonathan taylor going in the passing
game you've been saying all year rod get
back to the run get back to this big
offensive line in the run game how did
they do it on monday and what what'd you
see from their side of the ball there
with the colts well you gotta you have
to run the football i mean that's the
bottom line you can't sit here and make
carson wins the focal point of the
offense because and i told you this
before i think carson wins is going to
be the reason why the coach don't make
the playoffs why they don't go very far
i just don't think carson wins is the
answer to the coach problem at
quarterback and you think about the run
game they're dropping back passing the
ball and you give it to jonathan taylor
he's getting five six yards a pop so
feed him he's 230 pounds he's fast he's
hungry and he can get it done and
anytime they've given the ball to nahim
hines or jonathan taylor good things
happen but you cannot sit back there and
allow carson wentz to hold the ball he's
just not very good he's not playing with
a lot of confidence and let's not forget
about a guy like caleus campbell making
a huge play with the block field goal
chuck clark safety chuck clark
that no one really pays attention to and
this is one of the anchors on the
defensive side of the ball
for the baltimore ravens but if you're
the coach go back to running the ball
play action pass and getting the ball
out of carson wins hands as quick as
possible
but for indianapolis defensively because
you were texting me last night during
the game well you got to double mark
andrews you got to double up with tim's
it's hard to decide i mean they had 272
yards and four touchdowns combined if
you look at hollywood brown and mark
andrews so who would you try to take
away if this becomes sort of the future
now of what baltimore is going to do we
know how great they are on the ground
the long record they have of all these
hundred yard rushing games but if
they're able to now do this from the
passing game who do you try to take away
is it hollywood brown or is it mark
andrews because they both look pretty
great last night
well let me just say this mark andrews
is a player that i think that he should
get at least 10 well he get he should
get minimum 10 targets a game because
he's big he's got great hands he runs
routes like a wide receiver and i just
don't think there's many safeties or
even linebackers that can defend him
one-on-one and he's really good even if
you're playing zone coverage he knows
how to find the open is in his own but
you think about him in the red zone he
becomes a
a factor as well if if it's me being a
defensive coordinator i'm telling my
guys don't give up the big play to
hollywood brown let him catch the
underneath we'll rally and tackle him
but if i'm if i'm a defensive
coordinator i'm definitely taking away
mark andrews in certain situations in
the red zone third down because he is
such a good target and lamar feels so
comfortable with this guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports